so what a day uh deep divisions big
battles between democrats threatening to
derail president biden's multi-trillion
dollar cradle-to-grave government
expansion plan a plan that all top
democrats have promised would transform
the country
in totality
at this point no one seems to know
what's going to happen or how many
trillions democrats will ultimately
agree with each other that they should
spend
i plan on moving forward in a positive
way let me just tell you about
negotiating at the end
that's when you really have to weigh in
you cannot tire
you cannot concede
it's this is
this is the fun part i have voted pretty
consistently all my whole life
i don't fault any of them who believe
that they're much more progressive and
much more liberal god bless them
and all they need to do is we have to
elect more i guess for them to get
theirs elect more liberals the senator
thinks electing more
democrats is how you get it done
then that is something he should state
to the president because this is the
president's agenda we're on a path to
win i don't want to even consider any
other options than that we're in it to
win it president's also in it to win it
that's what we're working toward
so as for the moderate senator senators
like joe manchin and kristen cinema they
have become public enemy number one for
many democrats just watch all across the
media
mansion and cinema are standing in their
way they are the enemies right now of
the of the democracy i personally don't
think it's an accident that the
ones that a lot of lobbyists love are in
the much smaller underfunded bill they
are republicans come on no that's your
opinion they're both different it's not
an opinion they just look at the way
they are both the fact that one person
who is not affected by what would come
out of this record this build back
better act he's not affected by it
personally but the people in our
communities all across this country are
fascinating to watch uh this play out
you know um degen it strikes me that
there's this overwhelming desire for a
win because they've had a really really
tough month um between afghanistan and
inflation and all of uh the failures
that they've seen they really need a win
but i can't i every time someone says
that i'm looking at this and going well
does it really cost three and a half
trillion dollars just to put something
in the win column because this has major
ramifications well they're not happy the
left with uh one trillion plus win on
infrastructure a bipartisan package
that's been passed out of the senate uh
a a win for the far left could be a to
your point a a loss for joe biden but i
want to get back to that star wars
cantina media montage that we just
played the cluckin caterwaul and math
free hack fest they don't even know
what what they're talking about they are
for this
new age welfare plan simply because the
republicans are against it they don't
have any idea of the impact on the
future of the united states they have no
grasp of what is in it and chris hayes
had this embarrassing all caps rant on
twitter they got fact checked with
actual figures over and over again but
it goes to the kind of extremely harmful
and this is on the right to
view
widely accepted view that
if you're elected to office if you're a
senator elected by a state if you're a
congressman elected by your your
district and your state you're fully
expected to ignore your constituents
ignore your conscience
and just vote along party lines don
lemon the man who cried laughing when
that odious rick wilson was talking the
boomer rubes who voted for president
trump he doesn't care a flying dam about
the people of west virginia or the
people of arizona and it just also goes
and i'll wrap it up but it goes to the
craven power grab that these
democrats are so desperate uh to cling
to this control just look at chuck
schumer
this plan the three and a half is really
five trillion would hurt the economy of
new york and hurt his the constituents
who voted for him but he's more worried
about ocasio-cortez
primary in them so they do not the
chatterboxes don't have the best
interest of the american people at heart
and they actually have no idea what's in
these plans jesse i want to play this
sound bite from joe manchin today
because it was almost like he was
talking from another planet and to a lot
of people i think it made a lot of sense
uh he's talking about who he is who he's
always been and what he believes in as
an american senator watch this
i cannot accept our our economy or
basically our society moving towards an
entitlement mentality that you're
entitled
okay i'm more of a rewarding because i
can help those who really need help if
those who can help themselves do so
jesse senator is welcome to cross the
aisle and come to the republican party
any day he wants i think that would be
quite nice so here's what happened so
biden's unpopular and bernie sanders is
crazy so you have crazy and unpopular
get together and they're trying to nuke
through a 50-50 senate the most
expensive bill in american history joe
biden hasn't read it
joe biden didn't run on this this
thing's like this thick
i can't even pick this thing bongino
could probably pick it up you got
arthritis
i mean even even dan bongino can't curl
up
right so
if you look at what's in it this is what
billions for aoc's green army
billions to rig elections and dubai
votes
billions of freebies you know free
babysitters free lunches freebies for
illegals it's like a wet market for
welfare it's got everything so
why are we here martha because georgia
voters
didn't show up and we handed the
democrats the senate right that's why
we're in this position but
the great people of west virginia sent
joe manchin to washington and joe
manchin's basically went up there with a
sword
and sliced this socialist monstrosity in
half he says no no 1.5
trillion still wickedly expensive but
you know we're not going to give people
free stuff if they don't actually need
it so now this is joe
versus joe looks like manchin's
derailing this crazy train thank god
they may get something passed but it's
not that type of
money that we're talking about 3.5 it's
going to be less
and thank you people of west virginia
and as i said joe manchin is welcomed
across the island
i think the idea of means testing is
sort of like not in not in fashion and
it's such a basic common sense
you know joe manchin says jessica you
know we should give things to people who
maybe need a little help that's what the
safety net was designed for but this
this gives it to everybody so like you
guys have to pay for everyone else's
child care and you have to pay for
everyone else's ability to stay home for
12 weeks a year at a thousand dollars a
week you know companies cannot afford to
do that kind of plan so what i mean what
do you do you think this was
a folly is this a bad way to go down the
road or is this this makes sense
it looks like how unfortunately it
always looks before we get to the finish
line and if you saw nancy pelosi on the
phone last night during the
congressional baseball game you know
that she came to play and she usually
wins and she's going to figure something
out or wait a program means testing
makes sense
testing in some instances
for sure i think that there are certain
things blanket like with kovid where i
do think that people when you have a
national emergency like that who earn
under x amount just everyone should get
it not irrespective of what they have or
should they respect is it irrespective
of respect but i always get that one
wrong of what they have in their bank
accounts but this dance joe manchin and
kristen cinema do it regularly
and on the big stuff joe manchin has
sided with the democrats and been there
for really important bills that we
needed to get through signature
legislation certainly down the uh during
the obama years
in terms of the west virginia
voters and the arizona voters
you know we didn't pick up seats in
states that we thought we could win
right we thought susan collins was gonna
lose we didn't win that seat um joe
manchin has performed an incredible feat
that he wins by a lot in west virginia
there i don't believe there is any other
democrat that could win that seat and so
if you have to come down a little bit to
meet him in the middle of where he is
and he's been saying this also for
months that he's going to end up at 1.5
trillion that's what you do so you can
get the good stuff in the bill because
there's still a lot of good stuff in
there yeah i don't know i mean i don't
think americans and i don't think it's
just west virginia i think it's places
like north carolina virginia uh texas
dan where people are starting to pull
away from from these ideas and the
support of these ideas when you look at
their support for president biden well i
disagree jess shocker but there's no
good stuff in there i mean this thing is
a forest fire of uh you might as well
just flush your money down the folks at
home flush your money down the toilet
before the government gets it because it
will actually be better spent like
whatever the government spends money on
it destroys like you have a 3.5 trillion
dollar spending bill the largest in
american history you think we would ask
the basic question right like well what
are we buying well we're buying
government well does government not suck
no it sucks like whatever government
does it wrecks i mean seriously but
think about it right so we spend a
fortune on what public education yeah
liberals are always complaining oh no no
we need more it's so terrible we need
more you guys are paid your program like
private schools aren't complaining and
what else is government heavily involved
in what's the other sphere outside of
education healthcare where they pay
about 40 to 45 of every dollar what are
liberals always complaining about again
healthcare but they never have the big
argument they're like wait my gosh let
me scratch my head so i think big
government's a good idea where big
government's the biggest everything
sucks and we're always complaining and
yet we want bigger government to fix the
bigger government that really sucked
before it's like are you guys ever gonna
wake up and be like this is kind of a
dumb idea like government's really
terrible and maybe the private sector
can do this better there's nothing in
this bill this is the largest transfer
from i'm not saying this wrong either
from poor people and wealthy people to
the upper middle class in american
history read the wall street journal
article you could be a massachusetts
family earning 300k a year and you could
entitle yourself to about 20 thousand in
government benefits please explain to me
in what universe that's a good thing to
your means testing
it's like that in the united kingdom or
france or lots of places so wow i mean
look at how unstimulated their economies
are and and how much they have declined
baby boomers retiring a 112 trillion
dollar hole and so that's not even
factored into that medicare runs out of
money the hospital trust fund in five
years all right hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else